but the end of 2018 the plan is you will
be the first man to unify all four belts
and become the undisputed champion of
the world potentially that's the planet
that's the plan there's five but there's
five okay so you've got three so you
need these extra two and they're gonna
happen this year
yeah hopefully you are go to announce a
fight soon I think yeah who's the first
one with it was Ebro of the two
Burkholder so let's say there is a b c d
e okay and so on and so forth so i got
free of them there's two more left ones
in America
ones in New Zealand so I was looking at
both options America would have been
phenomenal cuz you know when I'm walking
down the street that lads like listen
mate I need a reason to get to Vegas
we've had some difficulty so we're
looking to bring yeah book by Joseph
Parker who's a tidy champion there he is
there he has one of the other belts can
I guess that looks like a try to be
quite an easy fine pie
[Laughter]
be a world-class athlete but he doesn't
look like one does he I mean you can't
underestimate you know the thing is with
books and I think you know the things
that you like you can make up for in
power in every weight division yeah and
there's not like there's not one
heavyweight that hasn't gone without
getting dropped in their whole career
and that's what I realized is that um a
lot of fighters have lost their titles
fruit underestimate and other athletes
like for instance Lennox Lewis when he
was he was filming I think Ocean's
eleven yeah and he lost his title cuz he
wasn't focused and no no heavyweight
champion is one heavyweight champion of
the world they're all two-time
heavyweight champion free time because
of the last thing they lose is the power
in their punch yeah so I can't even
though he looks like the pie eater so
I'm gonna be I'm focus I'm in training
camp now you know his secret weapon
armpit hair so he's got cat scan
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so they peel him off the floor they roll
him up like a carpet and send it back to
you zealand who's the american guy then
who's the next one you have to beat
he is dante wilder and got big mouth
here as you can see look at that look I
can say this is going to be harder I
think you're doing them in the right
order this is the plan Nixon this is
when the guys were out can get to Vegas
and have a good time or watch a bit of
boxing as well and this will be the
fight that makes history Vice
interesting because let's say I've done
the hard work so I managed to keep the
four belts and I've worked for
everything on the line to bring them
back home so it's a real tough one
because so what's the story to you go
into that match with four belts does he
then have five if he beats you correct
then he he creates history oh my god
this is the situation oh good noise at
that is that cinema sooo huge yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
I imagine you'll be quite nervous that
evening yeah that's a lot a lot but
you're also you're doing the fighting
you're preparing for all of that but
you're also you're doing some promoting
now as well which is unusual is it for
people when they're still boxing to do
promotion I've always had the mindset I
don't know I've always understood that
athletes kind of come to the end of
their careers and they say okay I'm
starting up a management company I want
a guide younger athletes because I think
it's the natural transition from
athletes or what I'm gonna do in
retirement but always for it's always
good to be two steps ahead of the game
and kind of use the momentum when I
compete in to kind of guide and help
athletes so like I'm I grew up in
Watford meter London
so I'm a proud sponsor of my gym where I
grew up so the kids that support them
and now I've got two of my good friends
who are with the management company and
then Laurence our Coley Joshua black see
were fighting for effort
and it's kind of guiding them giving
them the best advice and not only advice
they can bounce ideas off me as well
it's just like an organic relationship
and I know that sometimes people want to
see if the grass is greener and as I
said come to me for advice it's no
problem I know how the game goes and if
you ever want advice on where to go next
we can always guide you onto that as
well yeah and boxing now is like rock
and roll I mean anybody boxwood but
you've also mixed with royalty Prince
Harry himself good what did he ask you
to take part in his radio for program
yeah there's a picture yeah part is
ready for program it was an honor you
know yeah and yet before or after you
hit him
smiling at the six security guards
watching music
no real humble back go back
[Music]